- Hi, I'm such a fan of you!
- Thank you!
I'm a fan of yours, obviously.
- No, it's rare though!
I feel like when actors are
that talented where you do,
you can be funny,
you can be serious,
it's all the emotions.
I love all your movies,
they're so different.
- It's cool you just got right to it.
Thank you very much for saying that.
- No, I just really, not all actors-
- By the way I'll say this,
my daughter called me today,
who's at our ranch right now and she said,
"Oh my God, you're doing Kelly Clarkson.
Oh my God, like, you're cool."
(Kelly laughs)
Like you're really cool.
- That's like-
- So now I'm cool.
- Oh, that was like me.
Wait, that was me with my kids,
they're five and seven,
and Ariana Grande.
They were like, "You know her?"
and I was like sure, okay.
I do, she's awesome.
But I'm cool too.
- I have 33, 28, 3 and 1.
- Oh my god they're so that's very far.
That's kind of cool though.
- Yeah but I got that one thing,
like on the street where
they're like, grandpa?
And I go, no man.
- [Kelly] Oh no, really?
- No my deal.
- I feel like it's so normal now.
- It is kind of, I guess.
Is it normal now?
I don't know.
- We're in the entertainment industry
so I feel like it's normal.
- Agh, that's tough, yeah.
- I'm just saying.
I don't feel like it's maybe normal Like-
- No it's part of the contract
- no I think it's normal
- that you sign, you have
to have babies after 50.
- Hey, I waited until I was
30 to start procreating.
- Did you?
- Yes and I'm glad I did.
We can say procreating. (laughs)
- I could call it
something else if you want.
- Totally.
- I could get away with it.
- I was trying to be like family friendly.
No, but I waited and I'm
glad because I had a life.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Like I enjoyed my twenties.
- Yeah I had my first when I was 20,
19 when she was pregnant,
20, 25, 50 and 52.
And then I'll do 67, 82, 97. (laughter)
- I got a plan.
I like a man with a plan.
It's nice, it's nice.
- Yeah, it's good.
- I hope it's okay that
I mentioned the Goonies
because here's the thing
it's probably yours
since you've been gone.
That's the song, it's the only song
people think I've done in my career
I feel like sometimes.
And, I'm like, cool there's other songs.
And I know there's other movies.
There's a plethora of
many movies that you're in
that you're amazing.
But, this was your first movie.
- But this is the movie that
only means something to you.
- No, no, it's just, I
think of that coming of age
like whenever I was a kid,
like, first of all I watched
this movie with my kids.
- [Josh] Yeah.
- And I was like, holy (beep).
You can't watch this with your kids.
I forgot how much cursing is in it.
- Yeah, yeah.
- I was like, ah, ha ha ha ha.
And I was like, but yeah, I was like, ahh,
to try to be louder than
like what was happening.
But I didn't realize what I
was watching when I was a kid.
- But I'm watching you right now
like you watch the Goonies.
You talking about the Goonies
is as entertaining for me,
as you watching the Goonies.
- I'm telling you, I
was such a fan of them,
and it was one of-
- Who's your favorite character?
I'm sorry to interrupt, but
who's your favorite character.
- This is gonna awkward.
- Not that you have say.
- We were gonna get married.
So that's, that's why. (laughs)
No, no.
No, no, no.
This is our picture, this
is our picture. (laughs)
(audience applauds and cheers)
This is rad.
This is like the first
time I met Steven Tyler
and he was like, hi.
He was like, like, yeah,
we were gonna get married.
It's weird we didn't.
But it was you and Steven Tyler for me.
Yep and I loved it.
- Were you gonna have two husbands?
Is that what you mean?
- Yeah.
Well, I've already had one.
So who knows?
- Hey again, we got a
lot of those coming up.
Got a lot of those.
Goonies was the greatest
experience I ever had
in 38 years of doing movies.
Goonies was the number
one greatest experience.
And I went through like 20 years
because Goonies was really the
only thing that people knew,
until before I did No
Country and Grind House,
and then the trajectory of my
career changed a little bit.
Labor Day was in there.
So people would say the
Goonies during that 20 years
and you'd kind of cringe.
And then now it's a different thing
because you have other
movies that you can resort to
when they say the Goonies.
I love it, I love it.
I've gone back full circle.
- Too, because it was like
it was your first experience
doing something like that.
So that had to been like fun,
like camp, like with everyone.
I don't know.
It was like camp
because it was the first movie I ever did.
You don't do that.
And I thought every movie after
that was gonna be like that.
And I was really, really wrong.
Really, really wrong.
- 'Cause sometimes you probably
get on set and you're like,
I don't like these people.
- By the way you say
that most of the time,
but by the way so there's a
guy who follows me on Instagram
his name's Brad Tindel and
he's like a Goonies fanatic.
And he's gonna hate me saying that
but I reached out to
him, and he sent me this
which is an original patch
that we kept on our, yeah,
okay you guys aren't that impressed.
- I am and I actually just
thought of the actual jumper
that I'm gonna put it on.
- Okay, good.
There you go.
So take that.
- Put it on my green one.
It's gonna go here.
- From the ship, this
is an original doubloon.
- Chester Copperpot.
- [Josh] Chester Copperpot.
- I'm telling you I'm a total nerd.
- [Josh] I know, you know.
- I'm a big, you have no idea.
- So I'm a little let
down by your audience,
but that's okay.
(laughing)
- Don't worry, I'm here.
- I don't have those.
I meant to save those when I
was a kid, I don't have those.
So that came to me and that's for you.
- Oh my God, thank you.
I kid you not, I literally
pictured the jumper
I'm putting on, it's green.
- Good, okay.
- And I'm probably gonna
make that into a necklace.
Don't worry about it.
I have plans.
Is it true?
I did not know this, but is it true
that you had like a punk rock career?
I didn't know that, in the eighties?
- The career no.
I had a punk rock band.
- Wait what was your band name?
- The band, I can't say it on here man.
- Why?
- Rich kids on LSD.
- Why can't you say that?
Why can't, is this like a?
- There's one dude right over
there that's like (beep) yes!
- Like a self portrayed experience.
- So yeah, no, I started
in the garage version
of the band before we had the name
and then I was like quickly
fired 'cause I was a bad,
I was at, oh my God.
- I love this.
- Yeah I'm not in that
picture, but I love that too.
- But is this your,
this is the band though?
- That's the band.
Yeah that's Jason Sears
and that's Chris Rest.
Bunch of guys we grew up with.
- We didn't want the one with you in it,
We were like we want one
when they were popular.
I'm just kidding
- But don't you like, I mean,
you know how they tell you
like you being a brilliant singer
like they tell you feel it.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- That was us feeling it.
- I love that.
So wait, and so I wanna
talk about your new show.
So how do you explain it to people?
Because it's very different.
Like you feel like
you're watching a Western
and then all of a sudden
it's kind of supernatural,
which I love.
- I like it too.
I like the fact that it is
a straightforward Western,
the Western genre is very
simple, straightforward.
It's us kind of hearkening back
or longing to a simpler time and all that.
And then you bring in
supernatural elements.
So you bring in metaphysical elements
and you just turn the
whole thing on its head.
And to me, the interest is not necessarily
in the supernatural elements
but it's bringing something
so uncontrollable.
And then you get to watch
the kind of behavioral tweaks
that humans go through when
they can't control something.
Do you know what I mean?
- Yeah I'm in therapy.
- Well that's the same thing.
- So I definitely know what you mean.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Do you believe in the supernatural?
- How can you not believe.
Like we had something happen at my house
where it was like the
moving ta, and it really was
it happened at my house
where the thing moved
and three people saw it.
I didn't see it.
Yeah, yeah.
But I haven't seen that thing
like my kids walking in
and having black circles
under their eyes, like with
their arms out like that.
And I don't want to see that.
- That's when I'd move actually.
- I'd move too.
- That's when I would go bye.
- Yeah, yeah, me too.
- You can have this house.
- You believe in it?
- I do but I've never,
I feel like there's enough
chaos and unrest in this realm.
- Yeah that we don't really need it.
That I don't really need another one.
- You don't need it.
- Yeah and I feel like
anything in that realm
knows that I would die if I saw something.
Just like, just die, yeah.
- Yeah, no I understand.
- I would be so scared.
It would not be a good experience.
You know those people that-
- Would you go icy like that?
Like instant rigor mortis?
- Like those goats.
- Yeah like the goats.
(laughing and clapping)
- I swear to God, I didn't,
I didn't drink at lunch.
I did have half a
snicker, sugar is amazing.
- You know what you
remind me of and I'm sorry
I keep,
- A child?
- Child a little bit,
but my mother is from Texas.
- You do you have personality?
- Your momma was from Texas?
Yeah, from Corpus Christi.
- Oh my God that's where we all go.
That's a place you go for like the beach.
- Ocean and all that, yeah, yeah.
- I'm a Fort Worth girl, but whatever.
- Oh, right on.
- Does Fort worth ever cross your mind?
It's a good song.
Sugar does not do well for me at lunch.